Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen!
My name is Ryan Wang, and I'm a representative from the Metropolitan Transit Authority.
And it is my honor to announce that this subway car has been recognized officially...
...as the most courteous subway car in the entire New York City subway system.
We want to thank you.
We are providing you a pizza party,...
...so please give yourselves a round of applause for your outstanding behavior.
You have worked hard to reduce the amount of trash,...
...and this train has the lowest percentage of manspreading of any car...
...throughout the entire subway system.
Congratulations and please enjoy your pizza party.